what is going on there reject nation
greg and john here today so we are going
to talk about that brand new
announcement of that brand new daredevil
series coming to disney plus real quick
i know jeremy johns did a video because
it showed up in my notification bell
with what i'm assuming is a similar
title to this one just for clarification
purposes i haven't watched that video uh
when this news broke a couple days ago
this was like okay if i'm gonna talk
about this this is really what i'm gonna
want to talk about but we've been so
busy trying to get ahead i'm also in the
process of moving as well so we didn't
cover a video then so i just want people
to know i'm we're not stealing jeremy
johnson's video here but i'm sure we'll
probably have some intersecting points
jeremy notes yeah that's not what he
said no so we shouldn't say that if
jeremy didn't say it
but i'm sure it's better than whatever
we're gonna do here in this video yeah i
got some things i'm excited about it and
a good amount that i'm also concerned
about let's just dive into it so the
first thing i think we can we can both
agree on john what are we excited about
is the fact that our man matt murdock
charlie cox is going to be returning
that's been the revitalization a lot of
us have really wanted is for charlie cox
to come back some people have been
speculating like what if it's a
different daredevil i highly doubt
that's the case he was in no way home he
was at that disney event when she hulk
debuted its trailer they had kingpin
vincent d'onofrio appear in hawkeye i
think it would just logically make sense
that matt murdock is returning in the
form of charlie cox which i can't think
of any other better casting than the man
himself and also you know daredevil will
now finally get a chance to do
crossovers you know who are you excited
to see daredevil possibly cross over
with john goodness i mean i want to see
him on she-hulk i want to see daredevil
have to represent ant-man for something
i think that would be super fun you just
want to see a daredevil marvel lawyer
show that's right all i wanted from the
daredevil series is more law scenes and
that's what i hope we get here
especially with the mcu being on disney
plus and all the things we'll discuss
about that later well yeah i think that
we can finally get maybe a daredevil
spider-man true crossover at some point
but for sure something along the lines
of moon knight maybe blade there's all
the darker characters of the marvel
cinematic universe being introduced
getting a chance for daredevil to
finally cross paths with them is going
to be really exciting and this also
opens up the door to finally getting you
know characters like jessica jones
played by kristen ritter to come back
luke cage mike coulter that's right finn
jones danny rand
that's all people wanting that's all
people really want john bernthal's
punisher too yes who i wonder how that
would be on disney plus knowing that
daredevil's coming back that in and of
itself of course is exciting now i don't
think they're gonna you know completely
botch this but there were things that
instantly just sprung to mind the second
i heard this from like why am i not
super excited about this as excited as i
ought to be to be fair i kind of put
daredevil on an unfair pedestal i don't
know if it's unfair i just think
daredevil is the best marvel tv thing to
have ever existed i think a lot of
people would agree with you like i love
one division i love loki you know even
though i wasn't a big fan of the moon
night finale i think moon knight was a
fantastic show as well but i still feel
like daredevil at least season one and
three are the best marvel tv has ever
done the first concern that came to mind
is i think when people have been
demanding or at least you know
petitioning for daredevil to return it's
to continue the daredevil show to get us
back on path to season four of daredevil
from everything we've heard so far and
knowing that it would be on disney plus
i don't feel like this would be a true
season four if anything it's probably
gonna be a soft reboot of sorts even
charlie cox has commented on that in the
past so firstly it this doesn't seem
like it's going to be the thing that we
all really were wanting a because it's
going on disney plus and b the original
show runners of those seasons are are
not going to be returning i mean to be
fair every season did have a different
show runner however when you look at the
previous show runners works it made
sense how they could be brought on to
daredevil versus the situation here and
you had drew goddard guiding a lot of
things as an executive producer too what
we have here are these writers matt
corman and chris ord if you look up what
they've done the most popular thing
they've done is a thing called like
covert affairs which i have not seen any
of it sounds like it's a bit of like an
espionage comedy
is that what it is i i'm not sure 100
but that's just what it sounds like to
me i actually haven't seen anything
they've done so you know i can't really
attest to their work i was like looking
on rotten tomatoes and i see that a lot
of their shows often have a higher
audience score and a really low critic
score they seem like they're really good
for like network tv realm is where i
imagine most of their sensibilities most
line up bottom line is if you're not
getting the people back from the
original seasons of daredevil the ones
who brought the charlie cox rendition of
life just feels like this is most likely
gonna be a very different show and of
course it's going on disney plus now i
know marvel has been toying with going
darker as of late moon night was darker
and more violent than your average
marvel disney plush show as was doctor
strange as was doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness they were not
netflix daredevil r-rated no
they did not go down that path like i
really admire that they are finally
going there at least you know touching
the borders of it but if you guys
remember the vine a lot of people say
like it wasn't that violent like no it
was violent when it was violent it was
made it count and it made it shocking
enough that you remembered those acts
yes i mean a lot of people will flash to
like vincent d'onofrio slamming that
guy's head in and i think of like prison
fights moments from episode three where
the guy gets smashed to death with a
bowling ball then another guy sacrificed
himself by putting his head into a spike
it is gory it is violent and beyond just
the violence it's also incredibly
grim and gritty and
religiously heavy yeah
they really commit to a tone and a big
part of my concern of why they might not
go all out is yeah because it's going on
disney plus so i should probably
interrupt this video to say that yes i'm
aware that they have moved daredevil to
disney plus you can now stream the shows
there with the proper parental settings
adjusted this case however is going to
be billed as like a disney plus original
show
supposedly and with that they're going
to be wanting to promote it getting new
subscribers disney plus touts itself on
being like family friendly it just seems
like that if they're going to reinvent
the wheel with daredevil they would
probably have to water it down to make
it more accessible to families
b
we had the return of kingpin which a lot
of us anticipated a lot of us were very
let down there's a lot of folks who are
going let's give it the benefit of the
doubt it was just like one episode he's
gonna come back for more most likely
let's so let's just wait sure i'm going
to wait and see if they can make good on
that promise i was very disappointed
like very disappointed it wasn't like i
i wanted to be the same thing like it
was just a joke to me
yeah you wanted to see kingpin in the
same capacity of threat volatile terror
that you get out of daredevil and i
think it's really indicative of the
hampering that can happen when you look
at that hawkeye season finale because
the daredevil show probably wouldn't
have just done a cut to blood splat when
kingpin gets shot in the face spoiler
alert now we're in a universe that's
going to ask us to believe the more
heightened scenario that yeah he's gonna
come back from that most likely there's
a difference in the toll that the
violence takes where even if the acts of
violence are a bit more harsh for the
mcu as compared to before they don't
have the same stark real world-esque
impact that the show daredevil had i
can't imagine quite how it wouldn't feel
disconnected a little bit even though as
long as you have charlie cox and i mean
there are ways to shoot things and and
conceive things in a way that are
thematically dark to make things feel
more violent than they actually are but
at the same time i feel like then
they're gonna have to really throw down
on the writing of whatever
show or iteration daredevil comes back
in i think they're capable of that but
if you look at all the mcu shows thus
far a lot of them get to this point
where you're like this is really cool in
a lot of ways and it's got a lot of
potential but i feel like if you look at
most of them there are significant
complaints people have that often result
in i wish this had a little more time to
do more story and more flesh and i feel
like that's all the stuff that's going
to bridge the gap of the intensity that
will probably be you know lost with this
because even kevin feige was touting
moon knight as being this level up for
grittiness in the mcu but like you said
it's not that big of a level up to the
point where it feels like it could
approach rated r material also daredevil
i think too a lot of sensuality i would
say yeah it wasn't you know they didn't
go like full on nudity i mean the
netflix marvel shows would broach that a
little especially jessica jones wasn't
afraid to do that and that was the world
charlie cox inhabited was the netflix
marvel arena it's disney they're gonna
totally shine away from that i have a
lot of doubts based off of this doesn't
feel like it's gonna be an actual
continuation the fact that you would be
bringing it back you're setting up the
audience for a certain expectation of we
are finally getting our season four when
this is not gonna be that and you're
automatically going to be compared to
the three seasons that came before that
were very much loved and demanded that
this show comes back and it's not going
to be the same thing whether or not it's
going to be as good to be determined but
as of now um from what we've gotten as
of late while i've loved to liked pretty
much most of them daredevil's on a whole
new standard
for me of what i'd be expecting i do
have my concerns but what do you guys
think are you guys worried at all about
what they might do or are you just like
i will just wait and see we'll look out
for that trailer i mean well you know am
i being too negative here let me know
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that bell hit that like button and
we will catch you all soon